[Music]
royal tours are a key part of the job
for members of the royal family they can
be full of energy flag waving and photo
opportunities in recent times though
there have been some awkward moments
[Music]
and for some they have been a reminder
of the monarchy's difficult imperial
past
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
as of june 2022 the british crown was
still legally head of state in these 15
countries
all former british colonies or
protectorates
but increasingly there have been calls
for the british monarch to be removed as
head of state ladies and gentlemen the
royal highnesses the duke and duchess of
cambridge have arrived please stand
there shouldn't be
welcomed as leaders of the country as
representatives of the head of state how
these two young white people now going
to be here saying we are going to kowtow
to them and we are going to bend and
bow and kneel to them those days are
done those the monarchies are relic
in the caribbean some people want the
royal family to provide reparations for
their role in slavery
so what exactly are the monarchy's links
to the slave trade
the royal family's links to slavery
began during the reign of queen
elizabeth the first the crown and the
royal family was deeply involved in the
slave trade and making money off the
slave trade charles ii granted a charter
to the royal adventurers originally and
they were then reconstituted as the
royal african company to deal directly
in enslaved africans and to sell them in
the new world but primarily to the
colonies in the caribbean and mainland
north america this was uh one of the
greatest atrocities
in human history
and those who suffered
in this atrocity are persons from the
region a lot of persons from the
caribbean region
and that suffering was not only immense
it was generational
and
a lot of wealth was derived from the
suffering a lot of benefits was derived
from the suffering the brands that were
used on the bodies of enslaved people
featured the name of monarch so for
example the duke of york one of the
brands that was used by the royal
african company with the letters d-y and
this was actually instructed to be put
onto the bodies of enslaved people so
they are
are making it very clear that the royal
family is involved that the royal family
supports the slave trade and that
actually because the royal family
supports this is a good investment this
is a safe investment this was seen as
the way to build an empire but also as a
way to convert
africans to christianity that was the
primary argument that was made at the
time so the crown saw itself as a
civilizing christianizing force
that yes they were profiting and yes
they were supplying laborers to the
colonies but they also saw themselves as
on the right side because they were
expanding and civilizing the world
the wise african chiefs have seen the
tremendous changes in nairobi to which
the princess herself referred in her
speech the contrast we see today
is a striking tribute to the men and
women of all races
who have made it a great center of
commerce and finance
the crossroads of east africa the
capital of your colonies and the seas of
the east africa high commission
so of course that family has benefited
from enslavement um and so has many
institutions in this country whether
it's the railways the roads banks hsbc
barclays and the enslavers were
compensated when slavery was ended and
the conversation didn't stop getting
paid until 2015. so people like me were
paying actually for compensation for the
enslavers but the people who were
enslaved were never compensated we never
even got an apology
by the 1790s there is a growing
groundswell of support for abolition in
britain
but the royal family is deeply opposed
to the abolition of the slave trade
george iii did not come out publicly and
say that he was against the slave trade
but he made it very clear to his
ministers that he would not support
abolition as a cabinet measure
so this was something that the public
knew that the royal family was against
abolition that the royal family believed
that the slave trade was crucial to
maintaining britain's wealth and power
and its imperial interests
repairing that damage is something that
both prince charles and prince william
have tried to do in recent years with
some of the strongest words yet from
memphis the royal family when it comes
to links to slavery and some have seen
it as a real shift in attitudes from the
darkest days
of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
expressing sorrow but not saying sorry
and there's been so much discussion in
jamaica where they've just come from
about an apology for slavery how are you
feeling about that debate here slavery
will be not independent we now be given
freedom
okay so slavery to me it's been like
it's been abolished so why go back
in time you know and move forward
that it wasn't him
yeah that was it was that yeah
that was just
moving forward right now yeah
it's a better place yes and and that's
the best thing we can yeah yeah we are
prepared to forget yeah we'll never
forget
and we will always remember our history
we would always teach it but it actually
helps us to appreciate where we're going
and to know where we are going
in canada the anger that's been directed
at the royal family has all been to do
with the treatment of indigenous people
while the country was still part of the
british
empire in 2021 statues of both queen
victoria and queen elizabeth ii were
toppled on canada day
[Applause]
[Music]
it followed the shocking discovery of
unmarked graves at school sites where
indigenous children had been forcibly
taken from their families during the
reign of queen victoria my parents my
grandparents my aunt uncles and a bunch
of them do i went to residential schools
still scarred the community
so
it happened to our parents and
grandparents but it's still affecting
us
indigenous communities in australia and
new zealand have also taken issue with
the royal family
indigenous australians say that britain
never acknowledged that australia was
owned by aboriginal people before it was
colonized by the british in 1788
the colonisation of both countries
included violence it included disease
and dispossession and it certainly
included
massacre there's a whole range of things
that happen to aboriginal people
a number of communities and in fact i
would suggest most were impacted quite
profoundly by having
their culture either denied to them or
their language denied to them
in new zealand indigenous people have
protested the treaty of waitangi a
founding agreement between the british
crown and a number of maori chiefs the
agreement contained protections and land
rights for maori people that were never
honoured
in 1995 the queen delivered an apology
from the british crown to new zealand's
biggest maori tribe for the seizure of
maori lands by british colonisers
and in 2005 a topless protester wrote
get your colonial shame off my breasts
as prince charles toured the country
in recent times the crown has sought to
distance itself
from colonialism and racial prejudice
may i just say that while i'm here with
my husband as a member of the royal
family
i want you to know that for me i am here
with you as a mother
as a wife
as a woman
as a woman of color and as your sister
the one time someone from outside the
descendant of
um enslaved people married into the
royal family
she was not treated well
and alleged that she had been you know
horribly treated and ended up fleeing
the royal family and is no longer an
active royal
royal family a racist family sir
the image of the monarchy in some ways
is more important than anything and
by all respects they have failed um
especially recently with the treatment
of meghan markle the the royal tours the
backlash against the crown
none of it is good and none of it bodes
well for the survival of of this
institution
especially among the younger generations
and the mega markle case is really
interesting because she's a light
skinned mixed race woman she's almost
white passing to her certain extent
she's much lighter than me so she has
certain privileges that dark skinned
black women probably wouldn't have yet
she was still attacked by the mainstream
media by the social media trolls by
commentators by people inside the royal
family so that showed a spotlight on
this country that we're not as
progressive as we think we are that we
still have an issue with race in this
country and i think a lot of times we
think the race issue is something that's
just focused on america which is why the
uprising in 2020 i think caught a lot of
people off guard because they're like oh
racism just happens in america it's just
drug floyd but we never want to look at
the racism that actually is taking place
in this country
the royals still have a lot of support
overseas but in the wake of the black
lives matter movement there has been a
shift and we could now see countries
following in the footsteps of barbados
by removing the british monarch as head
of state
there is really no support for
maintaining some of these colonial ties
in the 21st century once the queen is
gone
they're all ready many colonies former
colonies leaving now while the queen is
still alive i think that is really the
most sobering aspect of this that
barbados has already left jamaica is
signaling that it will leave if these
former colonies are already now trying
to
sever ties and become truly independent
what is to stop other members of the
commonwealth is that okay for you like
like having the one family royalty where
it's hat where you know they're given
all the wealth all of the
that's not okay for us so as a black
person i just can't relate to a
institution that has been founded on
colonialism imperialism and enslavement
of my ancestors their imagery imagery
has been used as propaganda because they
are the new faces of colonialism they
are the new faces of imperialism they
are the new faces of social hierarchy
and and um class and i think a lot of
people are buying into that without
actually analyzing what these new
generations of royal family
actually represent
they are
the figurehead
for the colonial process but they are
not the people that did the colonialism
i belong to the indigenous community and
many many people that i know
are very supportive of the monarchy and
many would prefer that we were a
republic we shouldn't really anticipate
that there would be a homogenous
aboriginal view of any
any event
and particularly something as important
as say becoming a republic
you think it's time to become a
republican i think it's time to become a
republican right so just
let go of the slavery let lego africa
the queen
[Music]
just focus on
set a goal
and a direction